si colombia se diera cuenta de la gran
diversidad que tiene paisajes de
culturas de colores tan increíbles y
creo que sería una de las mayores
fuentes de ingresos
este departamento el departamento del
meta depende de la economía del 52% de
los hidrocarburos pero además somos el
mayor productor de hidrocarburos de
colombia y hoy estamos precisamente en
una transición para que nuestra economía
gire en torno al turismo y para eso nos
estamos preparando para eso vamos a
hacer una inversión de más de 40
millones de dólares en infraestructura
turística que va a impactar el 50 por
ciento de los municipios del
departamento
[Música]
y
aunque el
milan
[Música]
[Aplausos]